so one thing you still can't do in the
conference central application is that
you can't get the conference's that you
have registered to attend so now you're
going to go ahead and add that
functionality you're going to be
implementing the gate conferences to
attend method which is going to return a
collection of all the conference's that
the user has registered to attend this
list will continue to include
conferences that they've actually
already attended so it's not just the
ones that they will attend but the ones
that they registered to attend you're
going to work with the skeleton
implementation of get conferences to
attend you can find this skeleton
definition in the same file where you
found the skeleton definition for
register for conference so you're going
to go ahead and add the gate conferences
to attend method to conference API and
then you're going to implement the to
do's so as usual if the users now throw
an authorization exception because we do
need to know the user if we don't know
who the person is then how can we find
the conference's that they want to go to
and then you're going to get the profile
for the user and gain if the profile
doesn't exist got to throw another error
and then here's where you're going to do
the real work you're going to get a list
of the strings of the keys to attend
then you're going to have to iterate
over that list and turn every key string
into an actual key and then you're going
to have to load conferences for the keys
and of course return the list of
conferences alright so the first thing
to do is to add the skeleton
implementation of get conferences to
attend to the conference API and then go
ahead and fill in the to do's to
implement the function so one more thing
you might need to know is that you can
use ah feel okies pass in a keys list
and then call the dot values to load the
entities once you have a list of their
keys so go ahead and implement the get
conferences to attend method now then I
have a question for you why can't you
just return the value of the profiles
conference keys to attend property after
all we have this property conference
keys to
end so why can't get conferences to
attend just simply return conference
keys to attend is it because the
profiles tools conference name's not
keys or is it because the profile stores
conference keys add strings or in fact
you actually could do it it's just the
less efficient way to do it